Some vegetarians might claim that fish are
friends not food, I am not one of them.
But what if our fishy friends are actually
poisoning us?
Hey guys, Julia here for DNews
Thanks to recent trends like the mediterranean
diet, fishy meals are having their heyday.
Fish seems to be the perfect healthy food,
since they’re packed with omega-3s, which
could be good for the heart and some claim
it’s great brain food too.
Buuuut there’s always a problem in paradise.
Eating too much fish, might cause a buildup
of mercury.
Mercury builds up in the bodies of smaller
fish, which gets eaten by bigger fish, so
the mercury builds up there, and then THAT
fish is eaten by even bigger fish so they
get even more mercury… and so on up the
food chain, this process is called bioaccumulation.
So mercury bioaccumulates in bigger fish like
shark or swordfish, which wind up with pretty
big doses of the toxin.
But even more common fish like tuna and salmon
can accumulate decent doses too.
For most people this isn’t a problem, the
benefits from fish far outweigh any negatives.
But mercury exposure in pregnant women could
harm the brain and nervous system of a developing
fetus.
Exposure might be linked to ADHD issues in
their children, according to one study published
in the journal Archives of Pediatrics & Adolescent
Medicine. and the FDA recommends that pregnant
and breastfeeding women avoid eating shark,
tilefish, swordfish and king mackerel, fish
with the highest levels of mercury.
They also recommended limiting consumption
of albacore tuna to six ounces per week.
So where does all that mercury come from?
It is a natural element found throughout the
environment.
Some scientists think that it could be coming
from hydrothermal vents.
But it’s much more likely it’s thanks
to human activity.
We produce a lot of heavy metal waste from
power plants and manufacturing industries.
While some safeguards are in place, some facilities
have serious leaks or disposal issues.
So heavy metals like mercury get released
into the air and then find their way into
water systems and head out to sea.
There, the toxin builds up in fish, which
turn the mercury into a toxic form, methylmercury.
According to the EPA “Nearly all fish and
shellfish contain traces of methylmercury”.
Other animals are affected too, like coral.
Corals are really good at filtering out these
heavy metals from the water, unfortunately,
this can also harm them.
Just small amounts can kill them.
But their deaths may not be in vain!
Corals have given inspiration to a group of
Chinese scientists.
These researchers describe their new coral
inspired material in the Journal of Colloid
and Interface Science.
They made aluminum oxide nanoplates, which
have proved themselves to be pretty good removals
of pollutants in past research, but not ideal.
So the researchers created their nanoplates
to mimic coral’s structure and the way that
they curl.
By making a structure that’s porus like
coral it increases the surface area of the
coral, making it absorb all that nastiness
so much better!
So that could be a cool biomimicry solution
in the future - well, that along with green
energy and manufacturing solutions that keep
the oceans from being polluted in the first
place.
But for now, the FDA recommends eating at
least two meals a week which include fish,
just not any of the large species like swordfish.
But what about farmed fish - is that a good
alternative or not?
Trace explores that question in this video